yesterday i visited uh our friends and
family the cbs morning's
uh crew and um i ended up
discussing something with them
uh that i haven't told publicly it's
just been my very private little journey
and um
well let me let me give you a little
glimpse of it
i'm gonna say something for the first
time uh in a long time i have not had a
drink of alcohol in two and a half years
drew what is the biggest difference
between the drew that would casually
drink um in the drew that is practicing
sobriety
and
it's it's finally you know i love this
quote insecurity is loud confidence is
quiet
this was something i didn't talk to
people about for years because it was
this quiet confident journey
of just going
i just want to figure this out
and go about this with no profession no
public anything let me do this quietly
and privately and now it's been long
enough where i'm in a lifestyle that i
know is
really working on a high road for
my little journey
and there's so much peace finally being
had
it's so funny when we reveal ourselves
and our truths and the things we've
worked so hard for
it's so liberating and vulnerable all at
the same time and
i really want to attribute
uh this liberation and this moment in my
life to our first guest
i just really want to thank uh machine
gun kelly for
inspiring
the beginning of this journey
um i've wanted to go deeper on this show
um i wanted to pull back the veneers
and
he has really brought to this show what
for me has been one of the greater
honors to have this kind of a
conversation and it's really a testament
to him so please take a look
well it has been quite a year for our
first guest his latest album tickets to
my downfall debuted at number one
on the billboard 200. that's right
and he just won an american music award
for his favorite rock artist
he is someone that we all just love so
much oh and he's a budding nail
entrepreneur and artist as well
please welcome someone i've been so
excited to meet and talk to it's machine
gun kelly
[Applause]
[Music]
snail yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm so excited
so your new nail collection
undone lacquer yeah this is the one i'm
thinking i like this let's do this
i'm so i'm also
i'm like having a really weird day so i
just want you to
i don't want to
come off like i'm cold or i'm like shy
i'm just
i'm a little insular and i'm just having
an odd day
you're in a really safe space
um the other day i walked in here and i
started crying um at the beginning of
the intro we started hearing a pandemic
and everybody was terrified and i think
this show this space was born in a time
where we get to keep it very real and be
honest
maybe you can feel that in the room and
feel safe i think i'm
new to being vulnerable outside of songs
so it's like like i see a lot of
pictures of me
and there's like smiles on them and i'm
always like it's just weird though
because i didn't feel good at all that
day and i kind of
am
sick of smiling on days when i don't
feel like smiling and i feel like this
odd pressure because i don't want
um like my fans to
think that i'm taking something for
granted so if like i accept an award and
i'm like super smiley but behind the
scenes i was really
there was like stuff going on or i
didn't feel i don't know like a lot of
what i do is for other people and i
haven't given myself the
the time to just accept that it's okay
to not be okay so i i didn't just my
whole point is i just didn't want to
bring that into the show i'd love to
talk about funny stuff and anything that
you have for me i would love to just
like
i would love to just get out of what um
what i'm doing and like
i don't mean to sound creepy but i like
you so much more
i really do in fact we were just talking
about where different people were from
and someone was like
why do you know utah and i was like i
went there to go change my life and
i just you know i went through a really
painful divorce and i wasn't doing very
well and i just wanted to go talk to
some people and how to pull myself out
of a hole and i had
these two kids that i had to fight for
and um i needed help so i started
reaching out to different people and
eventually i really made some big
sweeping changes in my life
and i got i got on a whole new track not
back on track but a brand new one that i
helped build
with other people asking for support and
like i i'm all over the place too you
really are in the right space
who do you like go to for support when
you're feeling like this
well my girl is really centered and kind
of was like the one who encouraged me to
face my past and stuff and and
pick out what it is that
that i'm running from and why i like put
on those smiles that i don't want to
wear and stuff like that and so that
that was
big for me and i think also i was
like i was just walking behind my
daughter in the airport the other day
and like she just has this walk it's
this pure like bounce
she's so
excited for life like she's so young in
her life and i've experienced so much in
my life i just pray to
every god that exists that like she
keeps that bounce forever and doesn't
like no one interferes with that and
that she like that i always get to stand
back and watch her have that bounce like
i will take any amount of torture that
it
that would come her way if it can just
be on me so that she can keep that
forever because that's something that
it's like it's worth living for to see
that you know she's so
like
her voice is so sweet and it's not
tainted with like
what the world has to
offer and
anyway remember when you were in 50
first dates
i'm so
in love with my children
i never knew what life or love was until
i was born the day they were
they changed everything for me
and
whatever experiences i had or went
through they just made me think
i have to figure this out and
and and become a strong wise person for
them and now my daughter the other day i
got lost driving and i was just flipping
out behind the wheel and my daughter was
like mom
you need to take a deep breath
and calm down yeah and i was like
yeah
and i was like i just was so grateful to
her for being like now the roles are
reversed yeah no that's a she's she's
like my mom what was the last thing your
daughter told you
that like was smarter than what you
would have said or done the other day i
had to
witness myself being a rule follower for
the first time in her breaking rule for
the first time i was like
oh god what's happening i was at the uh
we i took her to greece
and uh her megan and i went to the
parthenon
and uh we went to acropolis and
we got up there and i made the stupid
mistake of like looking at the section
that's like restricted and
when i was like i bet all the cool
stuff's in there and
megan was like
well shouldn't we go and i was like nah
probably not i watched the mummy and
national treasure and all the people
that touched things that aren't supposed
to be touched and watched it go really
bad and uh
she was like well casey do you want to
go and i was like
in case she was like yeah and i was like
oh god i'm just gonna stay here
and they
went across the ropes and then like the
door burst open they were like what are
you doing and i was like and they
screamed and like ran away and we got
kicked out the parking lot but it was uh
yes
but uh
it's a proud moment there was also like
a proud mom was like this isn't a proud
mama but there was uh i got a call one
time where school was like hey so you
know your daughter got into
a thing with this boy and i was like
what happened they were like the boy was
talking bad about you
and i was like
[Music]
good job don't ever do that again but i
love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you